[موسيقى]
يعني اولا بيت صدام حسين من عندهم اخوه ما
يدخلون عن اخوتهم مو لو عندي اخ بس اجيب
لي عشرين اخ اني راح اشكرك واكون سعيده
انه لقيت لي اخوتي
راح احكي لك شي سمعناه من الوالد والوالد
من عنده ابن رئيس صدام منو يخاف يعني اذا
رجل عنده ابن يخاف انه عنده ابن يخفي عن
الصحه ليش يعني مدى اشوفها منطقيه الموضوع
هذا صحيح
في احد السنين كانت بالتسعينات ممكن 93 92
94 اقل حوالي
نجتمع كالعاده مثل ما ذكرت لحضرتك مع
الوالد على الغداء
كان لغط
يعني من هالنوع
الوالد يقعد
براس الطاوله واحنا نتوزع يمين ويسار غزه
كانه مقابيلي بده يحكي
قال لها ساجده وما يقول لها ساجده
اني عندي خمسه
اخاف فد يوم
يظهر شخص يقول اني ابن صدام حسين
[موسيقى]
تعرف كرئيس دوله اجهزه مخابراتيه يوصلوا
معلومات قيل كذا قيل كذا هذه من الوالد
موتك اخونا مو نقلا عن سالتني اكو اشياء
اقول لك اني ما سمعتها منك الله اعلم انا
هاي سمعت كل خواتي واخوتي وامي وكلنا
احنا الاشياء اللي لفقت علينا كعائله
كثيره هاي من ضمنها يا ريت بس ابن اختك
فلانه وانت زايحتها عن الساحه اسماء غريبه
عجيبه بحياتي ما سمعته
وبعدين كل فقاعه تنتهي يعني لو عندي اخ او
اخت هم شنو يعني شبح
قالوا ولد صدام حسين اذا موجودين عندهم
اسم ومكانه والناس تعرفهم بعدين كانوا
عايشين بالعراق ماكو ناس تعرفهم